I'm not going to participate in your
delusion you'll never meet a republican
that uses pronouns it's just a fact it's
only everybody uses pronouns just so
people choose to okay well my pronouns
now for the rest of the time are a
pretty princess that's pronoun those are
not even pron okay so what are your z z
z we are approaching the 150th episode
of middleground and we need your help to
continue making more episodes join our
middleground patreon community and make
middle ground with
us
my former political views were cult-like
can the agre please step
forward I I was going to say I think
both are just two separate Cults like
which is so funny and I think also sides
have like ironically kind of Switched
because as a republican now I'm like so
anti-war I'm anti- sending money to all
these different countries that are not
ours while people are sick from the
water and children are starving anti-
pharmaceutical anti- big government anti
all these things and I'm like that is
original liberalism so I'm like I think
I'm more like independent but I register
and I vote as far right as I possibly
can as well I think both sides are very
tribal yeah but in terms of cult at this
moment in time I think the left is more
cult-like I I was in it for 20 years
what's known today as the woke left but
we used to call it social justice love
Progressive love known by conservatives
as woke right but here are some of the
characteristics that I think make it
more cult like than perhaps the
conservative side one is that if you had
questions you had to check your
privilege or there was always some line
that they would use to get you to stop
asking questions which is sort of
cult-like and then the other thing was
there was this encouragement to separate
from people who didn't agree with you
and so I slowly over time like whittel
my world down to just people who are and
the social justice left and there was
really for people who left which I did
eventually which was a long process it's
a bit like you become an apostate you
you don't just leave or have different
opinions it's it's like once you leave
you can't come back that is a cult it's
like Scientology well I have perspective
cuz I came from a really religious
background and there's a lot of Shame
around believing something other than
what you're taught because of that it
makes you feel like you can't can't
express any questions without being told
that you're going to hell you're going
to be exiled from your family and so
when I started thinking a little bit
outside of the lines of what I was
always told family members literally to
this day will not speak to me will not
look at me in family gatherings where
you're just supposed to be like you're
my family aren't you supposed to love me
endlessly and in turn they've exiled me
because I don't believe the things that
they believe and I think that's horrible
yeah by the way I am ironically like
pretty far known as far right in my
community and then ironically very
leftist at times because you can't
please everyone but I have never cut off
a person because of their political
beliefs in my life but everyone on the
left did it to me I will say from my own
experience but coming from the opposite
so especially when the George Floyd
incidents were happening it was kind of
you know a consensus that you should be
BLM Rah r all cops are bad and just me
questioning that within my own circles
it's like there's a lot of push back and
it feels a little awkward because I'm
just you know it's literally just asking
questions if I did have to you know
point a finger I would point it at uh
the left or the Liberals for feeling
attacked by words that are said on the
other side cuz there's not a lot of you
know conservatives that are like oh you
said there's more genders I'm offended
I'm like a personally attacked by that
that's literally only one side it is can
the disagreer please step step
forward I honestly think that both sides
have very tribalistic Tendencies at a
time as far as the question like were my
beliefs personally cult-like I don't
think that I was in a cult and I mean
even I think you mentioned that like um
conservatives don't get offended by
speech as much but conservatives get
offended by pronouns they got offended
by Mr Pato head they get offended by all
kind really stupid things yeah they get
very they get very triggered also
was noticed started as anti sjw feminist
and I'm like the right is kind becom
this way too a little bit with some
things like very offended and triggered
I would like to push back a little bit
about conservatives being offended by
pronouns I think it's more so that they
are being forced and uh to acquest to
the pronouns of other people which is
you know a form of you know controlling
speech well don't conservatives get
really mad like when the whole pronouns
in BIO thing like look you have pronouns
I get what both of you are saying cuz my
thing is like why would I ever care if
you have pronouns in BIO but I will
never call you bio I think it's more
that people just view it as a tribal
signifier so in the same way that
someone might view oh that person has a
cross in their profile yeah I mean like
I've I've definitely like if I see
pronouns in someone's bio I'll roll my
eyes it doesn't mean that I like hate
the person or not but but it is going to
signify to me in 95% of cases I'm going
to know exactly what a I know exactly
who you are so I'm just going toay going
to assume that know a bu because someone
in their bio cuz I'm not going to
participate in your delusion and my
thing is like you'll never meet a
republican that uses pronouns it's just
a fact it's only everybody uses pronouns
just so people choose to announce
pronouns now for the rest of the time
are a pretty princess that's not a
pronoun not even okay so what are your Z
Z Z yeah I think pause sorry um I want
to pull it back to cult yes okay
circling back to the cult idea we kind
of straight in went to pronouns which I
think is again it's like a kind of a Hot
Topic the media really makes you believe
that one side is more of a cult than the
other that's all subjective some of the
people that were that are on my side
it's cultish but it doesn't it doesn't
mean everyone is well let me give you an
examp like cuz I I agree with the with
you that the media is is fomenting these
like right side left side Cults 100% I
agree with you um so like when I quote
unquote like left the left it was
because I had begun to question the
policies that were surrounding the whole
Co situation and I experienced cultish
on the left and the right for sure but
what what I found was if there were
people who were willing to listen to me
they were like 95% of the time they were
on the right about like I think the
government is trying to control us I
think that they're trying to force us to
do XYZ things I only found ears on the
right except in maybe one or two cases
so like for me I was like like when they
when the prompt is like oh the the left
is or or your former side is is a cult
like that was that was very visceral to
me there was a section of the right that
I could talk to and they didn't feel
like there was a section of the left
well you can always talk to me about it
sometime if you want more than happy to
talk to about the thank you my friend I
think Trump will win the next
election hey
hey love Trump uh I think he's the
greatest president we've ever had and I
I love him I've loved him for a long
time personality everything I will say
the more they do this Witch Hunt after
him oh he just keeps getting more and
more popular and you now that we have
free speech on Twitter you cannot deny
that people love him like the black
community is coming forward and and it's
just funny cuz I love watching them go
after him because I think elections at
this point are 100% fake and rigged I
just watch him rise in popular huh are
you going to think that if he wins I
mean with the entire world against you
I'd be shocked but I just think now it's
harder for them to hide it yeah I mean I
had major major TDS uh for his Trump
derangement syndrome um a lot of people
on the right have it they were like
obsessed with him and crazy thing thing
I I had I had major Trump derangement
syndrome uh through his pretty much his
entire first presidency except I was a
little softer towards it towards the
middle of 2020 but even so I didn't
really come around to liking Trump until
after he was President I went totally
like uh Republican um in my viewpoints
but I think that like I came around to
liking him unfortunately after his
presidency because I saw what we got
next and so now at this point I'm I'm
totally I'm I'm I'm voting for Trump in
the primary in the general um God
willing my life was way better then life
was way things I'm concerned that he's
going to win as well and I don't think
it's cuz he's the greatest president
we've ever had I think it's because the
Democrats have a branding problem um and
I think Trump is a brilliant marketer
and I think he's a brilliant con man and
I think he's done a fabulous job making
the case to the people who love him that
he's going to do what they want him to
do even though he doesn't so I think he
definitely can win I think they're both
wildly unpopular both him and Biden
totally um I think that there's not a
lot of great options I think the vast
majority of people voting want another
option and I do think that his base has
more enthusiasm than the Democratic base
does I think it's funny you say that cuz
I think that about the right I think we
have the worst branding issue in the
world I think the ride is so tacky the
Republican Party does Trump doesn't yeah
I no like I think the Republican party
is just so tacky 20 years behind but
it's funny cuz I'm watching farle people
come onto like my side now and I'm like
it's starting to shake things up but it
it's funny cuz I think if there was
another option between him and the
current vegetable we have and also Kamal
is so unpopular like you just have
double trouble with them yeah the
Democrats aren't they they're not
they're not putting up a viable option I
think RFK I thought was I think the
worst thing that the Democrats did for
themselves was like push RFK out of that
primary process love way I I like him
too now he's running as an
independent I'd like to start off um I
really do hope Trump wins I think it's
for the best interest of America that he
does unfortunately I do fully believe
that the Democratic party is a bunch of
political terrorists and I do believe
that they will do whatever they can to
steal the election you know it's a hot
take but from the last election with the
ballots I really don't think they're
going to make it easy like called and
said to find fake ballots I mean there's
a longer call that you could listen to
that debunks everything I mean he's not
going to end up in jail those all of
that is just you know a hit job but I do
think the Democrat party would rather
die than have him in power and I think
they could do that because people aren't
aware about the ballot fraud that's
going on h a quick just quick on that on
the voter fraud comments that you made
like what about yesterday Sydney Powell
just pled guilty to six counts of the
conspiracy in Georgia against the
election there so that that's actual
fraud that was committed on the right
side for Trump then there's probably on
both sides then but I would say it's uh
much more in the favor of seeing that
you know during the election count they
pause it and they you know mail in
ballots for Joe Biden I think we
shouldn't take guilty please at face
value because the justice system really
really I don't so I guarantee there's
fraud on both sides and it's all I think
it's all corrupt yeah I agree I don't
think he's going to win um I agree with
you I don't trust the last election
results but I actually don't trust any
presidential election results since
Kennedy so I don't I I just think I
think I think um I am going to vote
because screw them I'm not going to uh
I'm not going to allow them to instill
apathy in me but I don't really put a
lot of stock in national elections
anymore and um I think local is more
important so um I think that they
probably are going to not give it to a
republican this time around religion
played a part in changing my
beliefs join our middleground patreon to
watch this exclusive
prompt
Democrats are more compassionate than
Republicans I
agree fancy meeting you here I was for
someone to say something and you know I
hate it you you know I don't want to be
sitting here I will say I do think the
left hands to be more emotional I would
assume that that would come with
feelings of empathy and I will
say people on the right I am not
actually very popular on the right um as
soon as you disagree on certain things I
mean the death threats the hate yeah oh
oh so you're liberal now and I'm like
and there are certain things like
abortion is a Hot Topic um I think it's
uh it's a little it's a little crazy and
it's a little too far I would hope that
in the future I become a more middle
voic than the Republican party but I do
find in general like people on the left
I think because you're more emotional
inherently you're going to care more
about people's feelings I'm not really
one to care that much that's why I'm on
the other side you know what I mean but
I'll give you guys that credit I
actually agree with what you're saying a
lot because they've even done like
literal brain scans and they can
actually predict people's political
beliefs based on their brains up to like
80 to 90% accuracy like it's insane and
so I think well you're right that people
on the left do tend to think more so I
think it's with their left side of the
brain um that has more emotion
involvement which can be both a blessing
and a curse I think at times because
politics are also about factual
information and so feelings are
obviously not all that matter um but
yeah Democrats do tend to be more
compassionate at the end of the Daye
yeah and I when I was on the laugh my
whole life and like I was literally an
emo kid so it's like funny being on this
side now now I kind of like I'm a lot
more analytical about things I try to
cut the emotion as honestly a survival
tactic at this point I agree with that
too cuz for me in my personal Journey it
was very close to that like my mom used
to tell me that she's like you have like
zero empathy but I feel like as I went
through my journey not just like
transitioning in politics but just like
I went through my own kind of
self-discovery Journey and I feel like
empathy really came into play there and
I as I started to listen to stories from
people that had lived experiences I was
like wow you know I really do feel for
them and I can put myself in their shoes
and I I feel like now I'm even maybe an
empath like I'm very much you can
totally gain it and you can totally lose
it yeah yeah totally it's up to you yeah
but I do feel like since that I feel
like you know I am so much more
compassionate now towards you know
Humanity in general and people and as I
gained empathy I became more liberal AB
I think Democrats are much more
concerned with like social programs that
help people who aren't themselves um and
I I think that they often are the
leaders of the Civil Rights movements of
our time um and I think those things and
and leading policy with people first I
think is a bigger priority for them I
just not to say that Republicans don't
have empathy or compassion I just don't
think it necessarily leads their
politics so um Jonathan height has a
great book called The Righteous Mind
which I think everyone on this panel
would love it probably but in that book
he's trying to figure out I think the
subtitle is why good people are divided
by politics and religion and he divides
morality up into different types of
morality one of those types the one that
liberals and conservatives have in
common is the care harm principle they
both care about people they don't both
don't want people to be harmed but the
difference is that they have different
definitions of what's going to harm
people and what's caring for people and
I thought that was really interesting
when I started leaving um the left I
thought oh Republicans don't care about
people that's why they oppose raising
the minimum wage and it wasn't until I
started listening to other points of
view that I realized oh they oppose
raising the minimum wage because they
think it's going to harm people because
you're going to get fewer hours fewer
workers people are going to get fired
and so it's not that it's not that we um
disagree liberals and conservatives on
the why like we agree on that why we
should we should care for people we
disagree on the how I agree with that
100% um but not but but adding more to
that is my uh way of showing compassion
would be to tell someone that pick your
yourself up by your bootstraps like you
have more potential you can do this as
opposed to someone saying that okay the
government should step in and you know
support you and do XYZ for you um which
in the grand scheme of things isn't
going to benefit that person it's going
to teach them that they can rely on a
bigger being to to be you know their
support system but if you learn how to
pull yourself up I think you can be more
equipped to go throughout this world in
a successful way can't both things be
true I don't feel like Liberals are
telling people that they need someone to
pick them up and that they can't do it
for themselves I think they're saying
that there's that there's inequalities
in the world and that there's structures
in place that put people in a position
to where they can't get the life or the
things that they want the things that
they deserve and they they can do both
at the same time you can pick yourself
up and you can accept welfare and I
think that there's a lot of programs
that people have benefited from even
just be the ability to feed their kids
it doesn't mean that this mom is all of
a sudden going to not work because she's
getting welfare she's probably already
has two or three jobs talking from my
own experience I think if I'm being told
as I was that I am oppressed and that
there are systems against me I am not
going to have the same capabilities of
lifting myself up from that if I'm
maintaining the mindset that I am
oppressed and that I can't do something
instead of saying that I could have done
better I'll be like oh the system's
against me I am I feel like black people
are told not that they're told they have
to work twice as hard as so they do I
don't think that black people don't try
because they're told that they're
oppressed I think that they are told
that you're going to have to do more
because of discrimination yeah I think
um in terms of like you know uh
compassion I I I think that like on on
the right there's more like a a tough
love kind of thing where it's like you
have to do this for yourself we can't do
this for you but we want to we want to
like we want to encourage you to like
take initiative and you can be whatever
you want to be and I think you know on
the left it's like well we need to help
everybody to you know realize their full
potential I think both of those things
can be compassionate in just in
different ways and and I think I think
to a certain degree you need you need
both mentalities like we you know I
think we need to find middle
ground and uh and say that on both sides
are finding compassion I guess in their
in their that's why I step forward yeah
yeah changing sides was
traumatic
it was very very very traumatic
um I was I've grown on the belief you
know that you know black people are
systematically oppressed and that does a
lot for a young person's perspective and
when I started you know listen to the
other side and I started to dismantle
that Within Myself I felt like my whole
life was really a lie not only that but
I was also a pretty big Ally of the
lgbtq community and then seeing uh
transgender transgenderism dismantled in
front of me was also very discomforting
because I have um transgender family
members and I was very Pro uh lgbtq and
it just feeling that like everything's
just crumbling down it it took me uh a
lot of time to cover through it so it
was a
I remember the feelings very vividly I
mean I have a different perspective
because again we kind of are on
different sides of that Spectrum um I
was raised m militantly in religious and
political ideologies my entire life and
when I was 20 my sister was killed in a
car accident and um because of that um
and that extreme trauma that happened
that had nothing to do with my
ideologies um it allowed me to open up
my eyes to the struggles that other
people were going through because I had
never experienced something of that
Devastation before so I opened my eyes
to like what else is going on that I'm
not aware of that I've been in this
bubble being told that you know no one
else is oppressed I was just told that
they weren't real and that I had to be
steadfast with my beliefs and if I
questioned them then you know there was
this fear and guilt associated with it
and it caused immense amount of trauma
trauma that I'm still desperately
working through to this day I'm sorry
for L that's horrible
yeah um it's it's funny because we're on
different sides supposedly but um we
have a lot of similar experiences
because uh the social justice or woke
world I was in it for about two decades
I worked with comedians who also were
woke and and pushed woke beliefs in
their uh comedy and I really was a True
Believer in it I thought it was about
ending racism and sexism and when I
started started to question it it was
like your whole world crumbling I lost a
lot of friends friends um they weren't
friends they were allies that's the I
think right now I um ended my career and
changed my whole perspective and I think
the reason it's so traumatizing to use
that word is because it's not just like
you're changing one opinion on one issue
if you think of your belief system as
like a house you are literally um
bulldozing your whole house to the
ground
and starting over with Brick by Brick
what do I believe about this thing let
me I don't have an opinion yet on that
CU I'm trying to read about you know I I
had limited my myself in so many ways of
what I was allowed to listen to or
allowed to read or you know within that
cult there are people that you just
don't listen to I had never listened to
a lot of conservatives so and that's a
problem in and of itself too is um I
think to have a good um understanding of
just Society of people of both sides you
have to be able to listen I think think
not being able to have to inquire about
why someone believes something that they
say and then have a confrontation about
it is why there's so much Division I
think something I've learned through
this whole ordeal is that anyone
anywhere on any side that tells me not
to ask questions I'm going to
immediately ask
questions you know what I mean you
should be able to you should be able to
ask questions on either side and just
not feel like there's going to be
daggers thrown at you for it you know I
might not necessarily agree but I'm
allowed to hear what you're saying yeah
I don't want to shut anyone down like
freedom of speech you're allowed to
speak I'm allowed to
disagree I was on the fence with this
one because my experience wasn't
necessarily traumatizing but it was
definitely really
uncomfortable um my entire family are
all like staun Republicans Trump
supporters and I'm one of the only ones
that have actually branched off of that
and away from that and so I was silenced
pretty much because I was getting a lot
of push back and I was getting a lot of
hate and kind of being being bullied for
My Views and for speaking out against
them and what they believe feel like
that's the one thing we have in common I
don't think all of us had a beautiful
transitioning like I would like to put
it in a positive way it was the worst
time of my life I lost literally
everything which is weird cuz I always
feel like I've been the same Emily and
as soon as you put politics in it you're
like this different person like you guys
it's me I've always been this person but
I will say like on a positive note like
I lost everything and I'm so happy I I
did I would not have my boyfriend my
friends my career my spirituality I mean
it was the hardest and best thing that's
ever happened to me and if people go
through that I think you can either be a
victim or it could be the most hardest
most beautiful thing you ever go through
and I could not be more thankful I feel
very very lucky I think for me it was
less traumatizing and more empowering I
think knowledge is power and I think
when I started I grew up same as you
guys very very religious and
conservative tightly knit family um and
community and there was just a very
limited um allowance of what you could
believe um and there was a very limited
view of what America was what America
represented internationally um and as a
queer person it was also conservatives
were not super welcoming um and so for
me leaving that space and realizing oh
the United States is not the Beacon of
Hope that we wish it were
internationally and queer people are
allowed to be happy and and fulfilled um
it just to me it felt like freedom and
it felt like oh I now see how America
became the world's strong as superpower
and there's a lot of issues that come
along with that power um and with the
freedom we have it comes at the cost for
a lot of other people around the world
and I think getting that information and
knowledge it made me feel like my eyes
were opening to the real world and not
just what was happening in my community
and in this
country the Dual party system hurts
America
1,000% hey
everybody 350 million people in this
country there's no way we all have two
opinions exactly and it's crazy too cuz
we were just talking at the beginning
about Colts and it's like how do we
expect people to not become inevitably
really divided and polarized if it's
like are you on the right side or the
wrong side and that's it you know what I
mean so like depending on who you ask
they're going to tell you what they
think is the right or the wrong side but
when you were saying Robert Robert
Kennedy you were saying oh yeah he would
be a great candidate and I think he
would be able to maybe see both sides
now he's running for an independent how
often does an independent or a
non-republican or democrat win an
election maybe local but not not
presidential election so now we've maybe
potentially lost a candidate that could
see both sides and could actually make
change but when there's so much div
Vision on two sides it there's no way
that the majority of people in the
United States are actually going to get
a change in the ways that they need it I
think most people are more in the middle
and like have a lot more that they agree
on than they realize but this two- party
system and especially the media they
keep us divided they pit us against each
other it's funny because I'm like I
actually should be there because I
actually don't agree I think the two-
party system is working perfectly cuz
we're all at each other's throats yeah
and I think that's what they want it's
working for what they want it's working
for they want and not for what we want
it's actually perfect The Establishment
the political leaders it's like you have
% chance of winning every election
because the Country Split right in half
exactly and everyone has to be tribal
and we have to argue about things like
whether or not trans people or trans or
real people and that it stops us from
moving any sort of other conversation
forward stops moving forward R and the
DNC have no incentive to have like more
parties Congress puts forth any bills to
change the way that elections are done
or that with even getting people on the
ballot from other parties is well we're
like distracted fighting so we don't
know they're like poisoning our food and
water and we're all like literally dying
exactly and to Blake's point like I
think a good illustration of this
happened in the past couple years where
the coid policies first came down the
mandates and stuff they completely
exploited this right left thing and they
said oh wait no all the right people
over here and all the left people over
here and you know the 70 something perc
possibly of people who just kind of
follow went with their tribe they
successfully got us at each other's
throats about policy like mask and and
vac and did you get it are you going to
get it do you agree with the policy and
you know what happened we forgot about
like where did this virus come from and
now they've all come around now that
we've all been successfully fighting for
years now they're all quietly in the
mainstream media going like it probably
came from the lab that was studying
viruses like this like somehow it got
out sorry we didn't let you talk about
that back then cuz we we would have come
together but if we came together we'd
all go after them yeah yeah that's why
they don't want us to come together why
they don't want that they don't want us
to see this Middle
Ground I think my disagreement is pretty
simple the two-party system seems to be
a inherent flaw within democracy because
if the answer is to have more political
parties I think that loses its
efficiency and if it's to become one you
know it stops being a democracy and
where the two-party system fails we
should you know make some improvements
whether the two- party systems are
actually causing America harm I think
it's just the way you know America was
designed yeah why can't we change it
they don't want it to be changed cuz
they're making billions but what would
you change it to well that's do you have
hours do you have like 85 days what I
would say is that you know getting uh
down to one political party would you
know it would seem you know totalitarian
in essence but you know I think you know
the a lot of totalitarian societies if
there is a good moral head of of that
government you know it could do a lot of
good I would say Singapore it's illegal
to spit gum on the floor and that's
because of their totalitarian government
I'm pretty sure and you know but it's
also promotes you know deceny like Dubai
it's like you can't go over there and
yell and like shake your butt in a thong
and like I think that that
is like not okay to do either and that's
kind of totalitarian over there as well
those are like very little things that
you're giving up to have no control over
your own
life like Saudi Arabia also is another
example is like you will chop your hand
off literally if you steal and as a
result there is no crime imagine living
somewhere where there's
noed either
and want to talk about biased statistics
totalitarian government is not going to
be delivering accurate statistics from
within when they're saying hey we chop
everybody's hands off when they steal
and now crime is at 0% I well and people
feel like if they vote for a third party
that you're giving it to the other side
MH you know that's what I did in the in
the Hillary versus Trump election I
voted for Jill Stein and and when I was
doing it I was like oh I'm so passionate
about it I'm so passionate about it
because you know renewable energy green
energy whatever and then um I left the
ballot and I was like oh no wait hold on
is that just going to be kind of like
thrown to the side it's not it's not
it's just a process it takes time to
change and I think instead of like
trying to go to like a more restricted
Society it's like how can we fix
democracy and so it's like how can we
actually put power back into the hands
of the people and voting third party it
may not be this generation even that
sees the benefit but it's going to take
one person I think if Bernie Sanders or
Trump had run third party it would have
been a much different scenario but
people are afraid to leave the system
and RFK is trying it now so we'll see
what happens but it's even hard to get
on the ballot as a third party right now
I am still aligned with certain policies
from my former political
beliefs
I know the prom said policies but I'm
definitely still okay with certain
things that are generally seen more as
like the conservative thing I sometimes
do agree with conservatives about like
people being too sensitive for example
like I think that's definitely a problem
or the cancel culture thing I think is a
um totally like a fair issue that is
like a very real problem that can be
talked about so I think I when I thought
of policies I was thinking of like I
immediately went to the economy because
you know why we why are we going so far
overseas and billions trillions of
dollars go overseas but there are people
that are literally like outside of
Starbucks starving and I'm like where
what's going on like why can't we help
this person and that's where the
conflict comes because I'm like hold on
wait this is more conservative idea
however it's also a humanitarian which I
believe is like the root of it is we
just need to get to like a common ground
with that yeah that's literally me I
like America First yeah I was going to
say like make America great again like
that's not that's not old school bush
bush conser
why are we worrying about them when like
there is people like literally Starving
in front of me and I'm still Pro Choice
that's an extremely liberal thing in my
community um and other than that I care
about the planet I care about the
animals I care about reg I care about
regenerative farming I think that should
be the biggest issue being discussed
right now this the soil is we die
without it and that is something not
many people on the right are touching
and those are huge issues for me yeah
and like getting back to like indigenous
cultures and letting letting the
indigenous Nation they know what they're
doing we destroyed it well exactly we
have a country a territory Puerto Rico
that's literally impoverished in in in
in crumbles due to all the natural
disasters and yet we deny it and the
better we help ourselves the more we can
help them we got to get our
straight I think that um I came out here
to say I still hold a lot of the
positions I held on the left and it's
kind of funny because I think what's
left and right has changed we don't even
know what's up and what's down anymore
because I always thought when I was in
in the LA for 20 years you know I
marched against the Iraq War um I was
anti- corporations anti- big Pharma
anti-war and now I feel like things have
switched to such a degree that it's it's
more of the right who's voicing those
concerns when it comes to questioning
big farm and questioning corporations
and so I don't even know if that's
accurate to say I hold opinions that the
left holds because I don't know if they
hold them
anymore so I don't agree with um any of
the values that I previously had I used
to be a black supremist black
supremacist I used to be anti-American I
used to be a feminist I used to be an
ally
and as I've collected new information
and um evolved my understanding of the
world I am now pro-american I see the
alphabet Community as a acronym for
sexual perversions I see uh feminism as
inherent ly misogynistic and offensive
honestly and I see uh my past black
supremacist ways and a lot of pro black
things as very racist and uh so it's a
flip-flop and I'm used to be pro-choice
I definitely not it's obviously the
murder of unborn humans and I just think
it's crazy that we don't see that and
there's no way I could ever go back to
holding those beliefs uh because it just
would be wrong Never Say Never cuz
you've already changed once never I
don't really hold any conservative
values I'm sure there's some you could
find that I'd be like that's not
terrible um I don't really hold a lot of
democratic values I consider myself more
a progressive
populist um so I think both sides have
failed this country and the people in it
massively and I think everyone here
actually kind of agrees with that um but
we continue to bolster up the two
political party system um I think like I
said neither of them have worked our
country is eroding and deteriorating you
can't blame just one party because every
eight years the White House changes
colors and it's blue and now it's red
and it's blue and it's red Congress
flips back and forth and neither party
has been able to consistently stay in
power because they both suck so we get
one we hate it we switch we hate it we
switch so I tend to think it all needs
to be kind of wiped away rebuilt um and
rethought I think the experiment has
failed yeah it's fair and both sides
have their extreme you know far left and
far right and like most people are
generally in the middle but like I feel
like there's Nuance in things and people
forget that there's like you know it
doesn't have to be so black and white it
doesn't have to be one extreme or the
other and say you know with different
policies like abortion for example like
you know we can be you know pro-choice
but like agree that there should be like
a limit on when you should be able to
abort the baby like there's things that
people should be able to debate and
discuss and like come to um you know a
compromise on whatever it is there's
layers to things and I just think that
it's we're just such a black and white
Society right now I feel like we just
are so like extreme one side or the
other and that's why it's good when we
can have like we can come in and say
yeah like I agree with this policy on
this side but this policy on this side
you know instead of just being like
we're Banning abortion like can we just
find a middle ground right because we
just keep losing on this subject and I'm
tired of losing people are dying but
whether you agree with them or not you
just said people are dying someone with
that Viewpoint they would say yes
millions of unborn babies like they view
it as even if you don't agree it's the
loss of a human life is more important
to them than allowing the government to
have the say over what a woman does with
her body they prioritize it here I still
pro-choice which I know also my opinions
on abortion have been in flux for a few
years we should become more accustomed
to saying I'm thinking about this thing
for a long time yeah and like that's why
I don't hate on them because I think
it's beautiful and I'm also like a weird
Republican I'm literally pro-choice but
I go no you're literally murdering a
baby and I believe it's spiritually
demonic I still want someone to have
that right which is a weird thing
because I'm saying multiple
horrible I mean you know what's
interesting is is uh who I think you
were saying like um the experiment has
failed and it's like I think we've
strayed so far away from the experiment
I actually think we have to go back to
the Constitution which people have been
abandoning on both sides I'm not going
to say one side more than the other
people have been abandoning the
constitution on both sides so you know
and and and so I don't even disagree
with you I don't think the experiment
has failed I think that we've we've gone
away from what the experiment was
supposed to be I think we have to take a
good hard look at the Constitution and
say what does this say this is the
supreme law of the United States and
there's a lot of people who that's
inconvenient for and good it should be
inconvenient for the government it
should be absolutely inconvenient for
the government but anyway that's what I
think I love
that both sides kind of and that's how I
see